hello everybody
welcome to insane in the ending
it is a title that is evocative
of you know wildness
and sometimes the ending is wild and i
think part of the title
is to say or suggest the ending is not
boring
and the ending is a much maligned
feature
of the game i feel because there's a lot
of beauty in it
and a lot of times it takes a little
work to see it
to see how the ending is beautiful
and it is particularly not beautiful
when we use the words like technical
decision making it sounds dry it sounds
kind of nasty
and to that end today i'm going to cover
some examples that i got from this book
technical decision making in chess by
gail fett it just came out
i think it's pretty interesting we're
covering on the
on the chess dojo site we're doing a
book club about it
and it's given me the opportunity to
kind of go deep into each chapter and
spend
more time on each chapter than i might
otherwise do
the topic of my talk tonight is the idea
of inertia
in the ending and let me try to explain
what i mean by that
now a lot of people will be familiar
with just the idea
of inertia as a physical property for
example
if you have something on top of your car
and you're driving
and the car stops there is a force on
top of
uh in whatever it is you had on top of
your car
let's say it was imagine it's a notebook
and it's going to keep going it has
a force all of its own and there's a
whole interesting
you know history of science behind the
idea of inertias of actually a very
difficult
concept to formalize in mathematical
terms
when we talk about inertia in chess
i think what we're mostly talking about
is
how you can have a plan
and how that plan will kind of
keep rolling on in your mind
and it's very hard to stop having that
plan
a lot of times our opponent has to give
us some kind of rude awakening
in order for us to stop
having to stop doing the plan
excuse me and so
that happens in all chess positions
whether it's in the ending or not but
one thing
that i want to say that's just
interesting about the ending
is that you get
the ability for longer plans more
often in the ending and that's kind of a
weird thing like well why
and i think it's just that
you can plan more you can calculate
more the simpler a position is
and one of the weird things about when
we say simple is actually becomes
unsimple kind of often very difficult so
for example
here's a famous position rubenstein was
black against cone this is 1909
and in this position white played rook
c1 for better for worse
and now black has a plan very nice plan
to just go and eat this pawn
and you can calculate it out and it's a
very long
plan and maybe i'll just cruise through
it
to show you this classic example where
it's actually lost
now for white
and you can see now if fg the king comes
over and the point i'm trying to make is
that
when you get to the ending it's just
more possible
to um have a plan
and use it going forward now a lot of
times
plans are glorified as well they should
it's nice to have a plan
but what's interesting about plans is
they're not always the correct move and
it's difficult to readjust your thinking
when maybe the plan isn't going that
well
and there's another aspect why we see
inertia
in thinking in the ending more and that
is simply because
we are more often whether it's
uh you know weak gm's like myself or
super gm's
we are more often in time pressure
in the late phases of the game and also
that combination of time pressure and
being exhausted
is going to make us more reliant on a
plan
because it feels comforting and a lot of
times you just don't have that much time
to think about it so i'm going to show
a couple of examples and my hope with
this
is not only for some just some
interesting positions to share with
you today but also that
as a player you can sense just the
element of inertia and see it expressed
really clearly
in these endings and just realize that
it's something that's going on
in everybody's thinking and i'll talk a
little bit about more
what i mean about inertia but also as a
fan because we're going to be looking at
some games of very high ranking players
and um it's just an interesting
thing to see this aspect of inertia play
out
uh in these high-level games okay so
as exhibit a this is in the book and
this is
ivan chook against gelfand i believe
this is 2012.
and white has played just now queen to
b3
now let's talk about the position a
little bit
um the bishop on d2
is a little funny and why did it get
there because in this variation
black checked to make it go there
and the whole claim by black is that the
bishop is a little funky on d2
okay so then we ask ourselves well
what's the point of queen b3
and really besides a developing move
the virtue of queen b3 is that white can
say hey
at some point i'd like to trade
this bishop on d2 for this bishop on e7
i don't have to do it right away but
it's an idea for me with queen b3
okay so
that is already the seed that has been
planted
in chucky's head chucky being vasili
ivanchuk
for a lot of what happens next and
one human way to think about inertia in
thinking
is that we have uh what's often called
as
a sunken cost fallacy that is we
invest in an idea it could be you know a
material thing there's a various
ways to invest in things in our lives
we invest in something and then we can't
give up our
investment so we keep investing in it
and i think
that human trade is a lot of what
inertia
is about that we keep investing in an id
in an idea okay so let's look at what
happened
knight bd7 rook c1
and here i'd like to claim that there
are a variety
just a real big variety of moves that
black can do
which will leave his structure very
solid
here i'm going to mention
bishop d6 i'm going to mention h6
i'm going to mention a6 rookie 8 maybe
even 94.
all of those moves keep black structure
fundamentally
solid and pretty difficult actually to
get at
um so
gelfand played a move here that i
thought was truly truly bad
and he in this book
technical decision making calls it a
concession but doesn't really
think of it as a horrible horrible
horrible move
so let me just say to me the reason it's
so bad
is because white's last move rook c1
really just has one idea and that is hey
i'd love to
get something going on the c file right
and at the moment if it's white's move
there's nothing really going down if you
take there's nothing much happening
on the c file
now one great rule of thumb that i have
is every time a pawn move is made
you should reevaluate the position
but a lot of times our sunken cost
fallacy will get in the way
of us changing our minds and i think
that's a big
challenge for all chess players and as
fans it's just interesting to look at
and in fact i would say
it's that everybody is a victim of the
sunken
cost fallacy or inertia but
some players have learned to
pull themselves back from their
presuppositions better than others
and i think a good cue
for learning to pull yourself back
is to say whenever the guy makes a pawn
move
that's when we should rethink
the presuppositions in the position
because everything changes in particular
we can say oh right
now the rook on c1 truly is doing
something
okay so vasily played snip snip
and knight a3 bishop b7 and here's
uh where i want to address the key point
of the inertia in this position
to me for sure
the right move is bishop f4
for sure and
we know i looked at this when i'm
studying these games i'm looking at it
without the computer
and to me i just felt like no
black isn't going to survive and i came
up with all kinds of things of
because you know i was trying to imagine
like well what is what is black even
going to do
and you know
later of course i checked with the
computer and the computer surprisingly
says
it's bad for black but not the end of
the world and wants it to do disgusting
things
like 98 you know and
in any case i still of course like
white's position a lot but i'm going to
admit
that it's harder than i thought it was
going to be
when i first looked at this position in
any case to me it was just bishop f4
for sure is the right move and i still
believe it's the right move
but one of the things i reason i showed
this example is now chucky plays
bishop b4 and this move
also has venom in it but i think what i
want to say is
it's important to see that definitely
part of
his decision-making process came from
the let's call the sunken cost of the
ideas
behind queen b3 here
and for sure he's still a little bit
better here because you know that bishop
on b7 is terrible the knight on d7 is
terrible
but at the bare minimum now the knight
on
a3 is not so hot
okay now we could talk forever about
this game but i want to move on to the
next example
okay so here we have a really
interesting position
and um you know i think
as a kid i might have approached this
and said something like oh it's
rough you know it's equal or something
same about a plots
and in fact this is very difficult
for black
and the couple things maybe i should
say about it because it might not be
immediately obvious how difficult it is
for black
especially if the a pawn doesn't create
any drama
on the queen side what's going to happen
is that
white is going to be able to actually
conduct
an attack against the black king
using squares like f6 and his pawn
majority
on the king's side in addition to that
we have to note that the knight
on c7 is simply poor
okay so this for example i think is a
great example
for example is a great example this is
an example of
inertia here that girlfriend now sets in
motion
and what his mind is picking up on is a
pattern that we learn in
uh made in two exercises and i have the
big
book there that i use as a doorstop so
that my
my board doesn't fall down of the polgar
made in 2 book that i like a lot
and what he's going to dream of with
this move f4
is to do some nasty mate with g5
knight f6 let's say the king goes to g7
and then
squirrel around to g8 for a mate
and even if it isn't mate we're by by
crimping
the king like that putting it into a box
we can
we'll also have achieved something just
by making the king
ineffective right so f4 is a very
muscular move
and um what
uh he should have played probably is to
say to himself we really need to stop
rook d5 and the uh
move then that's very nice and actually
gives a very pleasant position for white
would be i think this move he doesn't
even say what movie thinks
uh white should play but i thought about
it and i just found this move very
delicious
because we stop any kind of rook d5
and we're preventing knight b5 and at
our leisure we can play something like
rook c6
and then do things like this
muscular plan that gelfand sets in
motion
with f4 so again we're in a little bit
of time pressure people are a little
fatigued
and what i want you to see is there's an
there's going to be
the ideas of this f4 move are going to
be repeated later and it's going to be
hard to
pull back from them so king g7
king f3 nice building moves and rook d5
and probably white in a little bit of
time pressure
missed that that black could do this
okay here we go rook c6
yes it's an achievement that black gets
to play a5
but black isn't out of the woods yet
and here on move 39 i'm gonna guess he
played
the natural knight f6 very quickly
why because he's been dreaming of that
the whole time
and um i think it would have been
very hard to say to yourself oh wait a
second
this knight d6 is in fact a far more
elegant move
we're threatening by the way rook c7 and
98
and on king f8 there's more brutality
with rook b1 and
uh you know really kind of a problem
here because we're threatening
rook b8 king e7 and knight c8 this way
very difficult and um another
nasty thing that can happen here is and
if any anytime
rook well yeah rook a6 we just play rook
b8
and if um on knight d6
rook 8 6 here
we play knight e8 very nice trick
and so there's a lot of tactics there
and so it would take a
little bit of
tactical imagination to play a move like
knight d6 but more importantly
it would require like rethinking what
your intentions of the last several
moves were
because you played f4 and king f3 with
the intention
of playing knight f6 after which i'm
sure in time pressure was more like a
thing where you're
going to say to yourself oh you know
what this just looks good
for me you know this just looks correct
for me in this position
okay and the game goes on and we could
talk about uh
you know the rest of that game as it you
know
it's its own interesting thing but the
thing i wanted to express was just an
example
of inertia okay let's look at our final
and maybe most complicated
but most beautiful example so here this
is gelfand as white against hari
krishna's black
from i believe it's 2014
and um it's a very
interesting position to me in the sense
that
um you know you ask yourself who's
better and why
and white has this dream
of playing rook c3
rook a3 and um
it's pretty barbaric you know to be
playing rook c3 a3
but that is indeed his point and
you know the the dream about it
is maybe to create some kind of weakness
and let's just say the dynamic that's
pretty obvious here
is just the question of obviously knight
versus bishop
but then more concretely
is the knight on e5 going to ultimately
be unstable with some kind of f6
and is that bishop on e6 going to
ultimately just have
more squares than the knight
bishops in general in positions like
this are going to be very powerful in
fact let's just put out
some let's imagine f6 happens and then
just count the squares
2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 that's a lot of squares and
the knight
of course will maximally control
eight and only when he's in this little
bounds
or the control eight squares so just
in general you know this bishop is
growing in power
as the game wears on as let's say the
dynamic
in this position okay so
um black now sets his own let's call it
inertial thinking in motion with a move
that i think is very impressive
and that i think i wouldn't know it's
beyond me
i'm sure that i would have played this
simplistic looking thing bishop d5
and would have been said to myself
something like i feel okay about life
um and that's probably true but the
bishop
on d5 is also a little bit like a rock
like why is it really there besides
looking pretty
you know looking like a big pawn on d5
so black plays rook d5
and the first thing we got to say is
it's
first a tactical response to the
let's call it the trick of rook c6
namely if rook c6
rook e5 so you have to see to that to
even
consider the move rook d5
and then the next idea is very
interesting
is on rook c3 his intention is rook b5
which i think
is all about bringing the queen to b4
and achieving
the end of the white attack
and potentially some kind of
better fisher ending fisher ending we're
just talking about bishop and rook
versus rook and knight
okay so i think that was the uh idea and
we're gonna see the inertia played out
in a second so white carries on with his
barbaric
plan of rook a3 and whenever you do this
kind of thing it's like
rushing the net and tennis you might get
burned by a lob over your head because
the rook
both rooks honestly the rook on it would
take a lot of courage
to see but the um
let's call it the inspiration for
finding the following idea from black
would really be about saying that the
rook on a3 is out of bounds
so let me first
show what black played he played a5
and this is an interesting mistake it's
not an end of the world kind of thing to
play a5
but let's first observe that the point
of a5
is still the dream of landing a big fat
piece on b4
namely the queen and saying to white you
know what
your attack is over buddy and that's
been my intention when i played rook d5
to b5 to get that queen b4 thing going
and i'm just playing a5 to stop your
queen a7 stuff and i'm going to land it
next move on b4 and i'm going to be
happy about life
okay so um
the let me just show the interesting
problem
with this is okay white says all right
rook c3
rook d8 and here
black does in fact play queen b4 and we
just go away
and the interesting thing now that's
transpired
is that the a5 move really
opened open black's kimono over there
he's a little bit loose
it's not the end of the world but he's a
little bit loose over there
and queen b4 is in itself
a mistake because um
you don't want to help the queen come
back to c2 the queen on a4 is no longer
doing that
much you know great great work we can
consider
things maybe like queen g5 or just some
other move rather than queen b4
but what you can see is it's an inertia
problem
and we get this in a variety
of positions um
and for example there's a saying where
we say mistakes come in pairs and
usually
in my experience we have a sense of a
position
a plan and then we set that in motion
and it's only really when we fall
on our face and usually it's two moves
it can be more
but it's only when we fall in our face
that we like go oh yeah now i'm gonna
stop doing those mistakes and like get
pulled back to reality and sometimes
we're lost and sometimes we're not if
we're gonna land wherever we land right
but in the end games i feel like it
happens
you can see it more clearly you can see
it over an extended period of moves like
this game
where he really is intending this queen
before move here
when he plays rook d5 way back on move
19 and we're here on move 23 so several
moves down the road
when you know several other moves at his
disposal
so now let me just conclude by showing
this amazing variation
really beautiful variation that black
has here
to punish white for his
aggression over there on the queen side
where i just have to admit to me
it doesn't feel like white has enough
pieces over there to justify
this kind of aggression but here we go
first i'm going to do it my way
we play queen b4
and there's no queen c2 now there's no
queen c2
because of queen a3 so you got to take
you've got to invite the king in the
queen but now the queen has trouble
coming back
okay then you say to yourself well i
guess i have to play b3 and that is
certainly a concession because now this
rook
is problematic and here is truly a
beautiful variation
check this out f6
knight g6 this is really lovely and
now if you play bishop c4 which you
definitely want to do
you got to worry about naida for
covering this guy
covering him up and maybe maybe maybe
the guy is going to survive
so instead you come up with this beauty
of a move bishop f7
and on knight f night h8 which
of course is the first question you got
to ask here is this lovely penetration
into the white camp and it's really a
great example
because these pieces are all left
wondering what they're doing and the
counter attack is now coming super fast
and hard
as an example i'll show rook c1
bishop d3 king anywhere
queen d2 and it's it's all over
surprisingly all over
really fascinating position um
and i i tried everything you know i
tried throwing
in um like some kind of d5 here
i tried everything it's just so
remarkable that the white pieces go from
attack
to refutation so fast but
it really is an example to see something
like that
of being able to pull back from your
original
intentions okay so let me go back and
show
that queen b4 would be the human way to
do it if you wanted to be
super cold-blooded you could consider
now
a6 because a6 is far less
weakening than uh a5
and in this this a6 move you're saying
i'm not even gonna give you the queen
trade anymore
and that's really you know that's the
really cold-blooded way of playing it
uh but of course ed what are we saying
because it would go like this
queen a6 and now queen b4
let's just note if b a knight c6 would
be the point
right so queen before
queen a7 b3 and we transpose
to this variation we talked about before
with f6
however just from a human point of view
you don't need to be that fancy
simply because in this position i think
it's fair to say
at least i would say that black is
better here with the potential of the
fischer ending and both
rooks are kind of funny anyway in this
position
okay so that's my take on
inertia and i think you can talk about
inertia and the sunken cost fallacy at
all
phases of the chess game but it's
especially clear
in the ending and so i just wanted to
share a couple examples
that for the most part i'm just hoping
will raise the awareness
of the fact that it happens and that
it's a very
human thing that happens and it affects
all players and as an ideal
both as fans and as players i guess we
can say to ourselves
as an ideal i would like to have the
ability
to retreat from my presuppositions of
the position
and that maybe that will help me do the
same
in real life as well okay i'll end it
there and
i'll be back next week for another
insane
in the ending bye bye